Hello?
Hi there.
How are you, Amanda?
Pretty good.
Oh, you sound very happy today.
Do you have any special plans?
Well, today is my birthday!
Wow, happy birthday, Amanda!
What are you going to do?
I have a birthday party tonight.
I'd like to invite you to my birthday party.
How sweet!
Thank you very much.
My pleasure.
By the way, next Monday is my wedding anniversary.
Congratulations!
When did you get married?
Didn't l tell you?
I got married two years ago and now I have twins.
Wow, twins?
Are they boys or girls?
They are a boy and a girl.
How old are they?
They are six months now.
Oh, I want to see them.
They must be very cute.
Yes, they are just lovely.
I will show you some of their pictures.
I'll look forward to seeing them soon.